they were in the same organization for
three years and never happened here's my
thing why can't it happen ESPN is in
business with UFC pfl is in business
with ESPN they do a co-promotion it's an
ESPN fight night don't have to be a UFC
don't have to be a pfl maybe that's
brought to you by ESPN they have the
money get it done why not do a one-off
of Francis John Jones if I'm UFC I want
John to fight Francis and shut him up if
I'm UFC I have all the confidence in the
world and John beating Francis let's a
ruin pfl's number one product yeah we'll
fight you don't have to be a PayPal
don't have UFC you both represent each
identity right go ahead and fight ESPN
put together John will let you do this
one off go and break this dude that's
what I would do